lisis Capaldi you watch his documentary
how I'm feeling now he's got this one
line in it that I just can't stop
thinking about Lis Capaldi writes this
first album songs that he was singing
since 2017 when he was playing them in
working men's pubs all around the
northeast of Scotland then he blows up
trillion bazillion streams and he's
asked to write the second album and he's
noticing he has stayed the same and he's
noticing the world treating him in a
different way and he's scared and he's
uncertain and he can't work out why
other people are treating him
differently he says Fame doesn't change
you just changes everybody around you as
you ascending stat as you start to
become more competent other people will
notice the difference in you more
quickly than you do and in poor versions
of culture they won't respond nicely to
it speaking to Daniel pink he talks
about how when your incentive structures
of performing a behavior change and it
becomes about making sure the people at
your record label can pay their
mortgages the enjoyment of the pursuit
of the thing itself decreases think
about the discipline equation friction
goes way up the psychological enjoyment
of the pursuit is no longer you in the
corner of the pub in Lis kali's case
where he said to me I want to go back to
the pub less pressure more psychological
enjoyment less friction